what we're going to do in this video is
talk about two related ideas that are
really the foundations of economics the
idea of scarcity and the idea of rivalry
now in other videos we do a deep dive
into what scarcity is but just as a
review in everyday language you could
think of something is scarce a good or a
service is scarce if there's not enough
for everyone another way to think about
it is a scarce resource is one that is
limited
it is a limited
resource
and there's not enough to go around
because there are potentially
unlimited wants from people so
potentially
potentially unlimited
unlimited wants and we could think of a
lot of scarce resources
oil would be a scarce resource there's a
limited supply of oil and potentially if
oil were free
there there's an unlimited amount of
people who would want to use that oil
and so a lot of economics is well when
you have a scarce resource like oil or
land or housing how do you allocate
those resources amongst people people
who are demanding those resources
now rivalry is a related idea when we
think about the everyday
word rival or rivalry you imagine
multiple parties competing for something
and that's essentially getting pretty
close to the economics definition of it
something is a rival good or a rival
resource i'll just call it a rival good
right now
if when one person uses it it limits the
ability for other people to use it so
one
one person
consuming it or using it
consuming it
limits
ability
ability
for others
for others
to
use and there's a lot of examples of
rival goods and things that are both
scarce and rival goods for example
if i were to put a nice delicious cake
that could only serve four people in our
office here at khan academy where we
have 80 or 90 folks work well you can
imagine that cake's going to be a rival
good it's also a scarce good because
many people many more people are going
to want that cake than the amount of
cake we have but when you look at what
the definition of a rival good is
every time i if i eat the whole cake
that's going to limit other people's
ability to use it
and economists will sometimes create a
spectrum of how rivalrous a good is so
for example let me draw a spectrum right
over here
so on this line so on the left hand side
i will call this highly rivalrous which
is they'll actually use that word but
i'll just call this
rival
goods
and then at the other extreme here i'll
say
non
non non-rival
non-rival good
and at the left end it's pretty easy to
come up with a bunch of rival goods if
you're living in a place where
housing is tight where
all of the housing is taken up
housing is often a rival good i live in
the san francisco bay area and when a
house goes on rent you'll have multiple
people who are competing for that house
or if it's going for sale and so when
one person gets it and gets to live
there well that's going to make it hard
for other people to use it you could
imagine you know land
in a lot of urban areas is a rival good
you could imagine something like
you know a cake especially if there's
not a lot of cake to go around
at a birthday party
now what would be the other extreme what
would be a non-rival good
well there are very few perfectly
non-rival goods but there are things
that are close to it because at least
relative to where people's where people
are trying to use it today it seems like
there's almost an unlimited supply of it
one example might be something that's
close i'm not going to put it all the
way at the end i'm going to put
air
air to breathe
on earth now right now it's a non-rival
good when i take a deep breath it
doesn't make it hard for you to take
another simultaneous deep breath and
actually let me put a little qualifier
here simultaneously
simultaneously
that's actually a key qualifier for a
rival good so for example a hammer is
also a rival good because if i'm using
it right now it becomes very hard for
you to use it simultaneously
now as i mentioned air to breathe if i
take a deep breath right now it doesn't
make it any harder for you to take a
deep breath but if you take an extreme
circumstance that let's say that if we
were in a closed room with a limited
supply of oxygen well then the air might
become something closer to a rival good
so let me put it this way air to breathe
outside
while here i'll put air
in
airtight let me put oxygen in an
airtight container or airtight room
oxygen
in
air
tight
room or maybe a room that is running out
of oxygen well then every time i take a
breath it's going to make it harder for
you to take a breath and vice versa
there's other things like well roads are
rival goods especially if we're talking
about rush hour so let me put this right
over here
so let's call this the roads during rush
hour roads during
rush hour
the more people that are on the roads
it's going to make it harder for other
people to use it simultaneously it will
get all this traffic people won't even
be able to get on the highway because
there's there's so much gridlock but
then you could imagine roads in the
middle of the night are non-rival goods
if i decide to take a drive at three in
the morning on most highways it doesn't
make it any harder for another person to
take a drive on that highway
simultaneously so let me put it over
here
roads roads at
3 a.m in most places is closer to being
a non-rival good
so i will leave you there these are
ideas that we're going to keep
revisiting in economics but it's good to
have a sense of what they mean and then
it'll inform how we think about
allocating these scarce goods amongst
folks and thinking about how we allocate
these rival goods amongst various
parties